und tag meine damen und herren mein name
ist justus bender ich bin politik
redakteur der faz und ich heiße sie
herzlich willkommen zur live fragerunde
die wir heute auf fasnet facebook und
youtube verbreiten
sie haben heute die gelegenheit mit mir
zu diskutieren und fragen zu stellen
zum thema 100 tage afd fraktion im
bundestag
ich persönlich berichte seit 2013 über
die partei habe viel erlebt höhen und
tiefen
viele vorsitzende kommen und gehen sehen
und habe jetzt auch mit großem interesse
die afg im bundestag verfolgt
ich würde gerne jetzt um die zeit ein
bisschen zu überbrücken bis sie die
ersten fragen stellen ihnen einfach mal
erzählen wie sich das so für mich
darstellt
jetzt die ersten 100 tage die afg hat
ganz klar von anfang an auch unter
führung von alexander gauland als
fraktionsvorsitzendem sich bemüht
seriöse sacharbeit zu machen
das war gar nicht unbedingt zu erwarten
weil die afg im wahlkampf wirklich sehr
harsche töne angeschlagen hatte sehr
populistische töne auch bauland noch in
der wahlnacht gesagt hatte wir wollen
merkel jagen
man kann natürlich jemanden jagen auf
inhaltliche weise und kann ihn sozusagen
im parlamentarischen prozess
vorantreiben mit inhaltlichen beiträgen
aber man kann auch in populistischer
manier ein parlament als bühne
missbrauchen
das hat die afd bisher nicht in
besonderem maße getan sie hat sich
eingefügt in die parlamentarischen
strukturen
sie hat sich an die regeln gehalten und
sie macht jetzt ganz normale
oppositionsarbeit durch anträge durch
redebeiträge durch das kontra geben im
innerlichen bereich und auch durch das
aufstellen natürlich von kandidaten für
die verschiedenen ausschüsse
jetzt schaue ich mal ob sie schon die
ersten fragen haben dann
gibt es noch keine ich würde einfach mal
eine frage beantworten die sich jetzt
schon im vorfeld gestellt hatte das war
nämlich die frage ob es etwas gab was
mich überrascht hat in den ersten 100
tagen
ich muss sagen es hat mich schon
überrascht was ich eben erzählt habe
dass sozusagen der der übergang von
einem sehr harten außerparlamentarischen
wahlkampf in zu einer parlamentarischen
arbeit die serie konform verläuft etwas
war was ich in der form nicht so nahtlos
erwartet hätte überrascht hat mich auch
etwas anderes was in der öffentlichen
debatte gar nicht so oft vorkommt wenn
sie sich mal auf youtube die reden
anschauen von jürgen pohl zum beispiel
den bundestagsabgeordneten fd aus
thüringen
der hält dort reden die oft an die
linkspartei gerichtet sind als
hauptkonkurrenten das ist das erste was
überrascht dass eine rechte partei sich
als konkurrenz zu einer linken partei
sieht und die redebeiträge die herr pohl
macht sind oft gerichtet an wähler die
wenig geld haben und was er wohl dazu zu
sagen hat es etwas was sehr links klingt
er kritisiert die hartz iv gesetzgebung
er kritisierte typische
beschäftigungsverhältnisse mahnt an dass
der deutsche sozialstaat mehr für die
schwachen tun muss und es ist schon
interessant zu sehen wie wie die afg als
rechte partei gerade ihren sozialen
flügel entdeckt und sozusagen auch in
der arbeit in der deutschen
arbeiterschaft beginnt zu werben für
ihre positionen und dort also ein
nationale positionen verbindet mit einem
sozialstaats gedanken der halt gerade in
diesem rechten flügel um die ecke in
thüringen zum beispiel wo auch herr pohl
herkommt gerade sehr en vogue ist
tatsächlich es gibt die ersten fragen
von ihnen das freut mich sehr denn
crosser fragt sollte man die afd
ignorieren oder lieber bloßstellen
da muss ich sagen als journalist bin ich
ja kein politikberater ich dann zu sagen
nicht zuständig dafür die anderen
parteien der den verein zu sagen wie sie
mit der afg umgehen sollten
es ist so dass ja alles ausprobiert
wurde von den anderen parteien das kann
man so sagen feststellen von außen erst
wurde die afg generiert dann wurde sie
in einer schärfe kritisiert wie man es
kaum steigern konnte
die wahlergebnisse zeigen dass nichts
davon einen sonderlich großen einfluss
hatte und insofern würde ich immer
meinen dass die eine eine haltung
gegenüber der afg die nicht von
taktischem von taktischen absichten
geprägt ist also eine haltung wo andere
parteien sich nicht überlegen was muss
ich jetzt tun um denen zu schaden was
muss ich tun um damit ihr nicht
profitieren oder irgendein
märtyrerstatus bekommen sondern eine
eine unpraktische haltung die nur vom
thema ausgeht
die nur beabsichtigt eine inhaltliche
debatte zu führen dass das etwas ist was
eigentlich also meiner meinung nach
angesagt wäre und das etwas ist was auch
die afg in eine position bringt wo sie
liefern muss wo sie inhalte liefern muss
wo es nicht ausreicht zu sagen es gibt
ein kartell der altparteien und wir
reden lässt sich nicht so sehr über
politische inhalte sondern bei
gerechtigkeitsfragen in der
auseinandersetzung mit einem angeblichen
kartell das ist so eine
eine sehr prinzipielle grundsatzdebatte
und eben kann innerlich die debatte und
je mehr wir uns in deutschland wieder
auf inhalte konzentrieren
umso mehr kann der wähler auch
beurteilen welche partei dann
tatsächlich die besten antworten gibt
würde ich sagen jetzt fragt florians am
sony welchen einfluss auf die ausschüsse
haben die vorsitzenden dieser positiv
wie negativ
er muss man ehrlicherweise sagen die
aufregung war natürlich groß jetzt die
vergangenen tage es gibt drei
ausschussvorsitzende der afg seit
gestern
es ist natürlich nur 1 1 ein präsidiales
am sozusagen das ist nur ein amt in dem
der ausschussvorsitzenden dazu da ist
das prozedere einzuhalten indem er
die tagesordnung feststellt die sitzung
einen beruf die sitzung leitet aber man
kann schon an dem umstand dass der
haushaltsausschuss immer schon in der
hand der größten oppositionspartei war
sehen das ist völlig normal ist das zum
beispiel im haushaltsausschuss der
vorsitzende immer überstimmt wird bei
jeder einzelnen entscheidung wird der
vorsitzende überstimmt es gibt sozusagen
keinen inhaltlichen gestaltungsspielraum
für einen ausschussvorsitzenden jenseits
seiner pflicht die das prozedere
aufrechtzuerhalten und herr böhringer
haushaltsausschuss hat schon versprochen
er wolle nicht den zampano spielen wie
er mir gesagt hat sondern er will dort
das seriös machen und dass er in der
vergangenheit radikale dinge in e-mails
gesagt hat wovon der manches bestreitet
das soll sozusagen das überhaupt nicht
trüben sondern er will dieses
symbolische amt oder dieses prozedurale
amt ganz seriös wahrnehmen
jetzt war konstantin kleine wie wird es
sich aus dass viele abgeordnete keine
brücke keine rückendeckung in ihrem
landesverband haben zb in nrw
das ist in der tat so ich erinnere auch
an herrn hampel zum beispiel den aus
niedersachsen der gerade sehr unter
druck steht ja auch im bundestag sitzt
die afd ist keine partei die schon so
stark in ihren strukturen gefestigt ist
dass diese begriffe wie rückendeckung
oder diese er sucht ihren beobachtungen
wie stark die machtbasis einzelner
personen ist dass das zu einem großen
unterschied macht also formal ist es
einfach so
diejenigen die vielleicht gar keine
rückendeckung haben sitzen jetzt im
bundestag haben ihr mann damit können
das ausüben und da kann ihn auch niemand
dazwischen funken oder sie unter druck
setzen und ich glaube das liegt daran
dass in der afg die erfahrung noch nicht
da ist wie ist es eigentlich wenn ich
eine legislaturperiode im bundestag war
und danach stellen mich meine leute
nicht mehr auf weil sie unzufrieden
waren
das kennt ja noch niemand in der ard
wenn das mal passiert es wird das
vielleicht viel wichtiger werden
die leute schon während der
legislaturperiode darüber nachdenken
hoppla besser ich stelle mich mit der
basis gut oder das war es hier nach vier
jahren
da das aber in der fdp noch nicht so
eingeübt ist spielt das nicht so eine
große rolle
meiner meinung nach jetzt zwar dough
grimm
finden sie es gut dass ein hassprediger
wie brandner als vorsitzender des
rechtsausschusses nahezu ohne widerstand
durchgewunken wurde nur um der afg keine
opferrolle zuzugestehen
solche menschen das meiner ansicht nach
kein derartiges amt bekleiden und so
jemand wäre früher nie bestätigt worden
jetzt muss ich sagen ich finde es nicht
gut oder schlecht ich finde es wenn man
mal umgekehrt fragt was denn wäre wenn
man ihn nicht gewählt hätte dann muss
ich sagen das finde ich schlecht weil
die was sich anfangs sagte die
verbindlichkeit der regeln des
parlaments die die afd
gottseidank respektiert und ein held ist
ein kostbares gut und wenn man jetzt
anfangen würde diese regeln auch nur zu
biegen oder zu brechen oder abzuschaffen
um der fdp zu schaden
dann verlieren diese regeln an
verbindlichkeit und dann wird werden
nicht nur für die anderen parteien sein
wird die afg als erstes sagen dann dann
müssen wir uns auch nicht an diese
regeln halten dann machen wir mal eine
kleine demonstration im plenum oder
rollen man transparente aus oder nutzen
die ausschüsse nicht für sacharbeit
sondern als forum für für einen auftritt
welcher art auch immer
insofern finde ich ist gefährlich
sozusagen ab zu abzugehen von diesen
regeln und sie nicht mehr einzuhalten
und umgekehrt muss man sagen wenn in
diesen regeln eine abstimmung vorgesehen
ist dann muss die afg sich natürlich
auch dem dem votum beugen das gehört
eben auch dazu wenn man sich an regeln
hält und insofern werde ich dafür die
fdp muss sich mehrheitsentscheidungen
beugen
aber umgekehrt sollten die anderen diese
regeln nicht beugen um mir zu schaden
jetzt fragt analysierte schön dass es im
parlament mal wieder debatten gibt und
nicht nur ein einknicken dann nicht nur
ein abnicken von entscheidungen die
vorher im stillen kämmerlein
abgesprochen wurden muss ich sagen die
die konstituierende sitzung des
bundestages in der es hoch her ging im
vergleich zu anderen konstituierenden
sitzungen sehr genossen
ich empfinde es als eine neue
lebendigkeit im parlament dass die
anderen fraktionen sich mehr mühe geben
aufgrund der anwesenheit der afg ihre
position zu erklären es ist eine
lebendige debatte
einerseits andererseits finde ich es
problematisch wenn man jetzt jede form
der lebendigkeit als positiven wert
ansieht es wäre auch denkbar dass eine
sehr sehr linke parteien noch links von
der linkspartei 1 1 züge in den
bundestag
dann könnte man auch davon reden es ist
ja toll dass wir jetzt hier im noch
lebendiger diskutieren
also ist immer ein schmaler grat aber
momentan empfinde ich die debatten im
bundestag auch als sehr interessant und
man sieht doch eigentlich wie toll das
parlament in der lage ist stimmung in
der bevölkerung aufzunehmen und diese
dann durch den parlamentarischen prozess
zu kanalisieren und in irgend etwas
produktives zu überführen also bin ich
sehr glücklich immer was den
parlamentarismus angeht
jetzt warten sollte man als journalist
mit der hfg wie mit einer normalen
partei umgehen
das sollte man unbedingt ich finde das
muss man sogar man darf ja den vorwurf
man sei irgendwie teil von einer einem
kartell aus mainstream medien die sich
alle absprechen um irgendeiner partei zu
schaden oder um die bevölkerung zu
manipulieren
diesen vorwurf darf man ja nicht dadurch
wahr machen dass man tatsächlich sich so
verhält wie es einem unterstellt wird
sondern man muss als journalist kritisch
nachfragen also der umgang mit der afg
bedeutet auch dass man die aufgabe hat
kritisch zu sein man hat nicht die
aufgabe nur mit zu schreiben was
fdp-politiker auf pressekonferenzen
sagen sondern man hat die aufgabe danach
zu fragen dann hat die aufgabe
nachzuforschen ob diese dinge stimmen
aber man muss dabei genauso vorgehen wie
bei anderen parteien und in der faz ist
es so dass die afg sicherlich die eine
oder andere kritische recherche erdulden
muss aber die anderen parteien müssen
das auch
und da haben wir glaube ich eine gute
tradition bei der zeitung dass wir alle
fair und gleich behandeln
jetzt andreas müller man muss die afg
nicht mögen aber wenn ich an den einzug
der grünen in den bundestag denke
erscheint mir die afg doch noch recht
zahm im auftreten
ansonsten gibt's ja noch
sanktionsmöglichkeiten nach der
geschäftsordnung des bundestages
wie sehen sie das ja ich finde auch dass
die afd
ich würde jetzt nicht zahlen nennen aber
sozusagen regelkonform und nicht
sonderlich populistisch auftritt im
bundestag bisher
und ich finde das gut ist beruhigt mich
dass diese sehr turbulente bewegung die
sich da gegründet hat 2013 jetzt in
diesem fahrwasser angekommen ist in
diesem parlamentarischen fahrwasser ich
hoffe es bleibt so
ich kenne ich bin sozusagen zu jung um
die grünen live erlebt zu haben
ein unterschied zu den grünen besteht
meiner meinung nach darin dass die
grünen in ihrem ersten programm sehr
klar gesagt haben wir haben die und die
forderungen und wir werben darum für
diese forderungen eines tages eine
mehrheit zu bekommen
das ist etwas anderes als das was die
afd sagen wir vor zwei jahren in
wahlkämpfen gemacht hat da hieß es die
anderen parteien verraten das deutsche
volk haben keine legitimität die fdp ist
die einzige partei die die meinte die
die rechte des deutschen volkes vertritt
und das ist ein gedanke der der
delegitimierung politischer gegner der
eben nicht ein reines werben um
mehrheiten ist sondern das ist
populistisch und das ist letztlich anti
pluralistisch anti parlamentarisch und
ich bin sozusagen drohen glücklich und
beruhigt wenn die afd weiter ihre
inhalte vertritt aber im
parlamentarischen prozess und diesen
respektiert dann fragt ein user
wie gehen die anderen parteien mit der
afg um
da gibt es große unterschiede meiner
meinung nach man hat das jetzt auch
gesehen bei den ausschuss-vorsitzenden
wahlen
wir hatten wir haben eine fdp im
parlament die er versucht die die afg
inhaltlich der innerlichen rede
sozusagen zu stellen also die die
versuchen die den diskurs zu suchen und
dabei eben nicht mit parlamentarischen
regeln irgendwelche damit zu ziehen weil
meine union die natürlich auch als die
fraktion die als erstes redet wenn die
afg einen antrag stellt klare kante
zieht und inhaltlich jeweils begründet
warum aus ihrer sicht der antrag der fdp
ist oder oder irreführend oder auf
falschen prämissen beruft beruht und wir
haben natürlich linke parteien die wie
auch jetzt bei der wahl der
ausschussvorsitzenden dann tatsächlich
sagen den willen bin ich und wir wir
blockieren hier und wir sind wirklich
strikt dagegen also es gibt da große
unterschied und nicht etwa dass das ein
kartell der sogenannten altparteien die
da irgendwie alle unter einer decke
stecken
insofern ist das sehr gemischt so ich
sehe wir kommen jetzt langsam zum
schluss einige fragen gibt es noch die
will ich gerne beantworten
sebastian g punkt fragt denken sie dass
in den medien wirklich objektiv
berichtet wird und finden sie es nicht
bedenklich dass in der allgemeinen
berichterstattung zu vielen
meinungsmache stattfindet die frage
bekomme ich natürlich sehr oft gestellt
ich finde immer also ich bin sehr offen
für diese kritik ich finde auch jeder
journalist muss sich dieser kritik
stellen
es ist nur die frage was ist eigentlich
die aufgabe eines journalisten ist es
die aufgabe einfach nur parteiprogramme
und pressekonferenz reden weiter zu
tragen ich habe manchmal den eindruck
dass manche fdp-anhänger sich das
wünscht von journalisten dass sie
eigentlich nur zur pressekonferenz gehen
und mitschreiben
ich kenne journalismus so dass
er eine wichtige funktion hat in der
demokratie er soll die die mächtigen und
die die politiker die leute das land
gestalten kritisch hinterfragen und und
das machen wir natürlich bei der afg und
ich rede hofft mit mit afd politikern
und die sagen oder hinter der hinter den
kulissen fällt denen sehr viel ein
warum es gründe gibt entwicklungen in
der partei kritisch zu hinterfragen und
auch artikel über diese entwicklung
werden dann hinter den kulissen nicht
immer kritisch gesehen vor den kulissen
aber wird werden die medien sehr scharf
angegriffen um eben diese rhetorik
aufrecht zu halten dass die afd
eine freiheitliche partei ist die kämpft
gegen ein kartell sei es ein kartell aus
parteien aus medien aus unternehmen usw
also ich sehe daher dass journalisten
ihre aufgabe erfüllen
so jetzt gibt es noch eine frage von
andreas lücke der sagt man sollte die
achte zeigen man sollte der afg zeigen
wo es lang geht und ihnen auch
politische aufgaben geben dann müssen
sie zeigen ob sie nur hetzen können oder
auch politik machen können durch
ausgrenzung machen sie sich zu opfern
der anderen parteien unter spielt ihnen
in die karten
das würde ich auch denken das ja auch
die aufgabe von bundestagsabgeordneten
nicht darin besteht im parlament zu
sitzen und ein bisschen schönreden zu
halten sondern besteht darin zu arbeiten
also richtig in den ausschüssen
sacharbeit zu machen das ist ja auch
anspruchsvoll und die ard muss hat es
irgendwie elan viel versprochen hat
ihren wählern versprochen dass sie den
politischen kurs in deutschland
grundsätzlich ändern werden und
helgoland hat gesagt wir werden die
anderen fraktionen so vor uns hertreiben
dass wir gar nicht regieren müssen
sondern wir werden allein durch unsere
anwesenheit den politischen diskurs im
land zu unseren gunsten verändern
jetzt ist natürlich die frage
wie werden sie das schaffen und werden
sie das schaffen werden sie mithalten
können
mit der fachlichen kompetenz vieler
abgeordneter die schon länger im
bundestag sitzen da müssen sich viele
fdp-politiker einarbeiten und dann wird
der wähler in vier jahren gelegenheit
haben wieder das zu bewerten und eine
entscheidung zu treffen also ich
beobachte das mit großer spannung jetzt
fragt elke klebt wie setzt sich die
fraktion zusammen hinsichtlich der
berufe und studienabschlüsse ich habe es
keine statistik und sozusagen vorliegen
aber es ist in der afg sehr gemischt
die partei galt früher mal als
professorin partei weil in der führung
dann mit bernd lucke und einigen anderen
natürlich sehr gebildete sehr viel
analysierende akademiker vertreten waren
aber man hat in der in der
bundestagsfraktion leute die kleine
mittelständische unternehmen haben oder
die arbeiter waren die angestellte waren
vor ihrer tätigkeit dort was man eher
weniger hat sind ehemalige beamte das
feld auf das finde ich auch sehr
interessant unter den wählern der afd
dass beamte die partei eher nicht wählen
und er arbeiter die partei wählen also
haben wir eine entwicklung und ansonsten
mischt sich die fdp-fraktion ganz so wie
andere das auch tun
jetzt sehe ich willkommen zum schluss
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für ihre
fragen es hat mir spaß gemacht ich freue
mich dass sie sich beteiligt haben und
sie können natürlich selbstverständlich
in der faz und auf fasnet in zukunft
wieder viele artikel zu lesen und wir
freuen uns dann auch immer über leser
kommentare und leserbriefe
vielen dank